hmm
I don't even know how this works
oh cool people are showing up okay this
is the first time I've tried this I've
never done this before so I'm just like
I'm just kind of shooting hoping this
open this works what's up guys I love
the idea of periscope but one of the
questions people had like one of the
concerns they had was that they couldn't
catch my periscope is this coming in
well for you guys I kind of feel like we
should switch to landscape maybe and
kind of I don't know I think this is
probably fine the way it is to be honest
I don't think it matters that much but
anyway yeah the chat is little chats
blowing up the Rob core yeah when I
figured I'd I do this because come a
couple people were like be gentle a
couple people were like I loved you I'd
love to catch your periscope so like I
don't have the app you know but uh but
yeah the best thing come out of DC we
worth right now oh my god these
questions this comment sections on fire
I wish there was a way for me to slow it
down so I could so I could actually see
what you guys are saying Rob let let you
buy me a beer yeah sure I mean that
works
can I please start to empower yourself
okay so here's the deal with that so
Benny's covering Power Rangers right now
I am beautiful thank you biddies
covering Power Rangers right now and I
didn't like we try not to step on each
other's nose the only time is if it
something big like Superman reborn is
huge
but he let me have the origin of both
tombs so I was like okay take super
Superman reborn so he's doing that one
but like when it comes to like the flash
and Batman like the button storyline
we're both doing that like that's coming
out it might even come down on the same
day but but I don't know so it sounds
birthday today no way happy birthday so
I don't think it is but anyway I talked
about Wally West what about Wally West
pcmasterrace
I thought I explained the merge Superman
in the story it's if Superman is pre new
52 Superman with all the energy and
power of the new 52 Superman now we
don't know how that works I mean that's
that's the question that's gonna be
asked is when did they split and how but
we don't know the answer to that
question yet so how do I haven't seen
the Walking Dead finale yet I've been in
Orlando and yeah I wasn't watching it so
I haven't seen it yet cover ultimate
spider-man again Vinnie's doing ultimate
spider-man so that's why I'm doing
regular spider-man oh yeah when I first
started liking her spider-man I didn't
expect it to be a series that would do
extremely well and it hasn't done and
samely well I did it someone because of
the fact that I wanted to have like all
of the spider-man stuff done going into
only wonderful Marvel by the time the
movie came out so I would just have this
massive spider-man playlist but who's my
favorite artist
oh my favorite artist in general is it's
probably Alex Ross Alex Ross okay what's
the bluth what's the blue stuff like
what is that when when your text comes
up blue I don't I don't know what that
means but Alex Ross is definitely my
favorite artist okay I saw that article
where Marvel was pointing the finger and
they were talking about how like artists
you know are the problem artists can't
sell books or whatever it is that's
stupid um like that's that's that's
nonsense artists sell books whatever I
look at like an Alex Ross story um
I look at Alex Ross art it kind of
invokes this feeling of a time when like
when superheroes were just like we're
good guys when there was no moral
ambiguity it wasn't like are they good
guys are they bad guys you know it
almost reminds you of a time like you
like I said this during a periscope but
you could almost imagine like Superman
you know when he's old he's an old man
you know he's the twilight of his life
or whatever it is he's you know he's
lived to see his great great great great
great great grandkids Lois Lane has long
since been gone and you could imagine
him like flipping through a scrapbook or
something along those lines you know and
he looks he flips it open and you just
see like this Alex Ross you know drawing
of like the Justice Society of America
and it's like we were heroes once you
know I could I could definitely see that
kind of being the case okay uh you need
spider-man vs. hell bat Batman are you
serious you to power spider-man versus
the hell bat
Batman unit power spider-man he's
Captain universe like he literally has
the power of the universe like it's it's
you know power spider-man I hate to be
that guy but it's it's you to power
spider-man I mean it'd be cool to see
them fight but it's you to power
spider-man like hands down for me it's
it's yeah that's that's pretty much it
Ethan Van Sciver is your favorite yeah
he's he's pretty cool he's he's pretty
awesome um no there's no supermodel next
to me I wish Candice Patton was next to
me whoa 20 bucks holy IV air yeah
will I ever come to California more
specifically Southern California okay so
one of the things that I've been
thinking about doing because I'm getting
I'm building a house you know getting a
house in in in California how City
Colorado one of the things I'm thinking
about doing is getting an apartment in
Los Angeles that way I can just kind of
travel back and forth between the two
places no I'm not married but I would
love to like actually go to to
California sometime and and you know
just like spend like a week there like
just vacation there or something like
that um that said I have been in Los
Angeles a few times but I've never been
to like San Diego San Francisco you know
you know say San Luis Obispo I guess is
how you pronounce it never been that far
south so Brian Reed's miss Marvel I
haven't have a red-brown reads miss
Marvel give me some wonderful on that
I'm not sure what what Brian reads miss
Marvel is what heroes villains would use
lists as contenders to unep our
spider-man ooh Doctor Doom definitely I
would probably say oh my god Rob's
livestream is a bit think about a DC
rebirth Rob I love your running
injustice because you bring in some
philosophy into I appreciate that um I
mean it has to be somebody with like the
power you know the power of the universe
or the power to challenge someone who
has a power of the universe so I would
say like okay where these donations
rolling in I wanna fly th e take each
one one by one so I would say like read
Richard or read molecule man Owen Reese
Franklin Richards definitely a handful
of others here and there but definitely
people who would have to like have the
ability to work reality on a universal
scale now that said smart people could
take em on so like Black Panther Reed
Richards like genius intellect people
could take him on somebody with and the
insane ability to like read minds or
troll minds like Charles Xavier but even
then it'd be pretty extreme in terms of
those guys if molecule man stole about a
beyonders power and is loaning it to
Reed and Franklin and make the
multiverse does that make him the new
one above all no it doesn't um
so there's uh that's a complicated
question does it make him the one above
all and it does not make him the one
above all it just makes him a being
capable of wielding the power of the
multiverse um we know the one above all
still exists that was confirmed in
infinity finale when Adam warlock was
bestowed as the New Living Tribunal and
the one above all spoke to them so no
molecule man is just a guy out there
with an insane amount of power
what is your end-all be-all of what is
your be-all and end-all favorite comic
of all time
because one of my all-time favorite
comics is Silver Surfer Requiem good
choice Silver Surfer Requiem is amazing
I would say my favorite end-all be a
holy Bryan more than 50 bucks Wow
my favorite end-all-be-all comic is
definitely is definitely the this
century like Marvel Knights at this
century okay a couple people who haven't
done it yet I'm gonna make sure I also
answer your questions I don't want you
guys to feel left out rob do we have to
read Green Lantern core for Geoff Johns
Green Lantern no but it makes for a more
fulfilling story um there are a couple
times where it's necessary but it makes
for a more well-rounded story it's like
you don't have to read Avengers if you
want to read Hickman's you want to read
the events leading up to the collapse of
the multiverse all you have to do is
just read New Avengers but reading
Avengers makes for a more cohesive story
um
beta ray bill in the MCU god I hope so I
want to see someone legit like pick up
Thor's hammer I really want to see that
why can't Marvel and DC do ever do a
crossover because of the 1990s both
companies were struggling financially
and it made perfect sense for them to do
crossovers in order to bolster
themselves it was like hey look you know
like if we crossover people will read
our comment from both sides so we should
do that nowadays that financial you know
insolvency isn't really part of the
picture anymore and so they're just like
screw you guys we're not crossing sauce
on season 1 of Legion Legion was amazing
it was probably one of the best x-men
based
anything that's ever existed outside of
the comics
um the way they played it was genius
like like the way they played it like
where you didn't know if it was in his
head wherever it was real that was
absolute genius and I loved it um
overall I really want to see uh season 2
they set it up for that but I would say
that that they could stop right now and
that would be it and it would still be
amazing but I'd save season 1 of Legion
is probably one of the best shows that
was ever produced and the fact that they
made it 8 episodes was was stellar
um do I think Superman will die in
injustice - no idea I'm kind of hoping
he doesn't actually I'm kind of hoping
that in justice Superman doesn't die
because I loved his character I would
love to see him kind of you know go back
to the to being a good guy but I also
see him I also I would love to see him
fall like further down the path of being
being a bad guy um my run on injustice
please explain did you write something I
sure ba no no no when people when they
were after saying my run on injustice
we're talking about the stories that
that I that I went over what are the
types of kryptonite's like pink pink
it's sort of I don't know them all off
the top my head my voice is so deep like
Darth Vader I don't know them off the
top my head I know variant I think has a
video on it and Benny has a video on it
I might do a video on that when it gets
closer to the release of the Justice
League movie but I'll tell my head I
know all the same ones you do like red
kryptonite makes them mutate random
mutations green kryptonite takes away
his powers and kills them you know I
know the the arbitrary ones ASMR junkie
to watch Wow
Thank You ASMR junkie okay so so there
are so many questions here okay
I'm trying to answer your questions guys
are prophets okay answer them I hope you
guys are enjoying this I'm trying to
answer them please do berserk um I don't
know anything about berserk I've heard
of it and you guys have been asking for
it but I wouldn't even know where to
begin
if I wanted to read that stuff from
Toronto thanks Rob Rob thanks for all
the videos and putting me on no problem
I'm sorry if I'm answering your
questions late I'm trying to scroll
through these and and answer it answer
as many questions as I can this course
is just rolling in like crazy I'm trying
to make a comic and I would like your
opinion and advice and help if possible
if you are insightful
hitting some rope some blocks in the
road simian script what you have granted
Sal's probably the better person to ask
humming pop knows the ins and outs of
writing a comic book so he's probably a
better person to answer than me but but
I'd be you know I could give it a shot
Rob is there any chance of you covering
my girls green arrow in the future yes I
want to start launching like a day on my
YouTube channel where I'm gonna focus on
more adult-oriented content and then
start like if I were to do a green arrow
I'd start with longbow hunters and then
go out into the rest of my crows run
those guys who don't know my crow made a
vertigo story with Green Arrow called
longbow hunters and it was it was like
it was like Punisher match it was really
really dark and it was really good it
was really mature but then they turn
around and spun it out into its own
ongoing series before he left and then I
don't member who it was it took over
after that have you thought about doing
an episode on the Marvel noir line of
comics I've thought about that I've read
through them the only issue I have is
that they don't really seem to strike a
chord with me and so I have a hard time
doing stories that I'm not that I don't
have like you know a whole lot of
interest in make your Justice League
without any original members really Oh
rejecting gamers thank you for a buck my
own my own Justice League without the
original members
all right guy Gardner definitely Guy
Gardner he's a guy at one my corner um
Kyle Rayner is the white lantern guy
garden would be would be a Green Lantern
Kyle Rayner is a white lantern um
superwoman
probably Metamorpho if we could get him
to be a good guy Amanda Waller as a
mastermind of the team
she'd be kind of like the Batman
replacement uh and maybe Harley Quinn I
don't know I mean I'm just I'm kind of
grasping I have to put a little bit like
a lot more thought into that in order to
pull it off I didn't like how many books
until I found your channel if they give
her so thank you so much for sharing
your videos with us keep it up thank you
for watching
thank you for giving a damn about my
content jacob fairy two bucks Thank You
Jacob it's always crazy to see that it's
like it's like they like me they really
really like me like you guys care it's
just like wow it's really it's really
exciting all right who would win Odin or
the Celestials the Celestials they've
actually fought before and they they
destroyed the destroyer armor what do
you think of season 1 of the Netflix
series iron fist I enjoyed it I thought
it was send nudes i really enjoyed iron
fist i thought was probably one of the
best shows running at the moment it's
it's definitely pretty stuff in terms of
how it all comes together and how it all
functions it was something that I
thought was pretty pretty solid dude
cover the Buffy comics um I don't know
Buffy had comics am I ever gonna come to
Chicago
yes I'm actually coming there for c2e2
yes I will be there
mysamma comics touring are gonna be
there and I believe we're actually gonna
have a panel can you just say my name
buster is your name buster you asked me
to say hero on PC
I don't know what are my favorite books
outside of the big two valiant
definitely um I was it was a little slow
for me to get into EXO Manowar but I
definitely dug I definitely dug exo-m an
award just you know I don't know which
was just being interesting I don't know
if it's more grounded you know it's
seeing a guy with with a suit we
basically what amounts to an Iron Man
suit times a thousand is really cool
because he's basically a displaced man
aside from that it would be like
Harbinger probably sex criminals is a
really good one uh Scott Steiner
switches is amazing
what is the odinforce the odinforce is
essentially just this emag Matic source
of energy frodan it's like the life the
life source of like his brothers or
something like that it's never
explicitly stated what the odinforce is
I don't think but it's basically just
his power is really all it is
what are your thoughts on the upcoming
Green Lantern and Space Ghost crossover
um never a big fan of Space Ghost why do
people keep saying nudes never a big fan
of Space Ghost I dig it but was never
like the biggest fan of Space Ghost
I mean I'll read it because I'm kind of
curious again I'm sorry from behind bars
I think like maybe like 15 minutes
behind on your comments but there are so
many rolling in
I love the channel brother I'd love to
get my books on to come to see TV too
and I will sign it for you
yo Bob will you come to do our Comic Con
this year it will be my first Comic Con
and I'd love to meet you yes I will be
there we usually always make New York
Comic Con the only time I didn't make
that is when my friend had a wedding and
I couldn't I couldn't miss it
Eric Hernandez thank you for five bucks
all right let's let's go down a little
further holy is there a Kure $100
holy freak thanks for everything you did
for me and my wife she loved your
channel if you are lost on the wife part
as Vinny okay how do you feel about the
Living Tribunal killed in the new cosmic
entity composed of master order and Lord
chaos and the in-betweener not really
sure what direction they're taking with
that I wouldn't say it was bad but it's
definitely weird things are gonna be set
back to rights but we know like Galactus
is devour
world's now I'm curious what direction
it goes in I will say that I'm curious
what direction it goes in but I feel
like logos cannot be a long-term cosmic
entity in the realm of Marvel um hey Rob
big fan since one will explain keep it
up
Thank You Shawn m4 $50 Wow Believix
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen what
is the meaning of life it'd be easier if
you asked what is the answer to life the
universe and everything because then I
would just say 42 the meaning of life
fine happiness fine whatever does it
makes you happy and keep doing that I
don't know how else to answer that
question um let's see dr. Manhattan
versus Franklin Richards
dr. Manhattan he's just more experienced
with his powers as all it comes down to
that's it if we were talking about adult
Franklin Richards even then I might say
dr. Manhattan but I'm not sure could you
cover the Dark Knight Returns um never
really thought about that before well I
guess I've thought about it but never
really given it a whole lot of credence
um I guess I should I mean it'd be kind
of cool to do that what do you think
should I cover it give me a yes or no
down there tell me if you guys think I
should cover it or not all right so so
okay a couple some non donation
questions cuz I feel like I've been
answering a lot of donation questions
any more Walking Dead content I get this
question all the time we are caught up
so we have to wait for the next story
arc to end before we can cover it can I
do more Nightwing yes I'm waiting for
the current story arc to end and I want
to do more that being said I really
think that like Shawn I think her name
is is one of the coolest characters
coming out there like the graffiti chick
I think she's one of the coolest
characters in that story right now what
do you think about the new Justice
League trailer we talked about that in
the weekly pool but I am I'm excited for
it man Aquaman dude Aquaman riding on
the Batmobile this looks it looks badass
favorite Lantern ring um probably read
I'm a huge fan of the Red Lantern Corps
I think a lot of people are you know
just like they're just aggro
they're just raging all the time let's
see
our Zeus and Odin different characters
if so who would win yes Zeus and Odin
are completely a two two completely
different characters and I think Zeus is
the more powerful of the do not gonna
swear to that but I'm pretty sure that's
the case well second guys let me turn
this like this charger into the wall
thoughts on Tom Kings Batman a war of
jokes and riddles as well as Batman
metal um I'm looking forward to the war
jokes and riddles I mean I'm excited
about it Tom Keyes Madden has been
pretty stoic
I mean I'm digging it so far like I'm
really didn't getting into it kind of
draws questions I'm answering as many as
I can guys I'm really trying to answer
as many as I can so so if I don't answer
your question right off the bat just
keep your question coming just repeat it
and then I'll try to answer it it's just
like what we used to do comics a coffee
now we just got a zillion people showing
up as asking questions and stuff
thoughts on Jeff Lemire stano's comic
it's one of the best comic books out
there right now like it's it's
hands-down one of the best I mean it's
it's great I mean I'm really diggin like
the whole idea of like Fame and his
vengeance against his father and so on
it's pretty stellar it's definitely one
of the best that I've ever seen
yeah I'm going to get current on X
amount of War before I do more valiant
comic stuff but I'm definitely digging
valiant at the moment best Robin
greatest two worst ooh
greatest is Dick Grayson I'm sorry Tim
Drake fans but the greatest is Dick
Grayson after that I would say it's
probably Damian Wayne and then Jason
Todd and then Tim Drake and then whoever
else after that Stephanie brown or you
know Kelly Carrie Kelly or or however
but is the adjusted story done yes and
justice one is finished we're waiting
for injustice to right now and I think I
might just cover that each week that it
comes out will a Matsu me Kobashi get
covered I've never thought about doing
the chaos King a lot of people want me
to do the chaos King and and I might do
that at some point that was actually
that was technically part of Greg packs
so uh Greg packs incredible whole kind
of enough really but it wasn't really a
necessity bad really I mean I don't
really have much of an attention to
cover but I guess I could um how is my
dog my dog is good Max is good he's at
home right now and I really want to get
back to him I miss I miss max I miss my
dog uh cosmic spider-man versus Superman
prime 1 million in cosmic spider-man I
mean the ability to just alter the
fabric of the universe is just it's just
beyond Superman 1 million what a storm
became the next sorcerer supreme I feel
there is some untapped potential story
well actually there really is there's
some untapped potential to do a lot with
storm um the issue is it right now
Marvel setting our character back to
rights and so she's just going back to
be part of the x1 which makes sense I
mean it's the smart move for them to
make with her character you know kind of
build her out from the x-men and go from
there that being said um the issue with
storm is that you know as a mutant her
role is within the mutant community
that's where she shines brightest is a
leader you know was a champion for
people who feel cast off people who feel
segregated things like that she's a
great great role for that she's a great
you know a great character that kind of
be a field commander or even take charge
of the x-men in the absence of Charles
Xavier um
having said that ya know um I could see
her being sorcerer supreme but it would
almost kind of feel out of place they'd
have to do it really in a way that would
work otherwise it's just like hey your
storm sorcerer supreme what do you think
of the Batman costume used by Ben
Affleck and Batman vs Superman I loved
it I thought it looked beautiful it was
definitely one of my favorites do you
think The Walking Dead is really a story
through Carl's eyes
never thought about that um definitely a
strong possibility but in the end of the
day I think it's just told the
perspective of Rick's eyes I mean it
could be that like you know you know
Robert Kirkman we're bringing all to an
end and it turns out all of it was just
told from Carl's perspective and he's
sitting around a campfire just telling
this tale I have no idea but the only
issue is I mean it'd have to be
something was told to him by Rick you
know as time progressed but I don't know
Robbie make how much epic I hope in the
future I can get you to explain my
copybook once he gets some content yeah
send it to me and I'll make a video on
it
check out ketogenic you affect my life
with for the better so I want to affect
yours for the better
oh you mean like going into ketosis is
that what you're talking about because I
know I know all about that
oh man versus Ozymandias damn that's a
good one uh old man versus Ozymandias
Paulo man Ozymandias is cool and I love
Ozymandias his character and as smart as
he is I don't know if he can take on
Bruce Wayne as Batman or owl man or any
of that I don't think it works goku vs
superman who wins and why I really don't
want to touch that that's such a
dangerous road
got that so dangerous I don't know I'd
say probably Goku just because of the
fact that his power is limitless
he just keeps getting stronger and
stronger but I don't know what am I
gonna cover powers from Marvel Comics
I've seen Bendis writing that then I've
never actually read it I know he's other
works there but I've never actually read
it before Wow is that 10,000 yen holy
cow
hey Rob babe Fran from this Oh from
South Korea okay so that's what South
Korea I love your videos I'm going to
the army in like two weeks so I won't be
able to watch your videos for a couple
of months so grats on your 1 million
subs in advance oh thank you so much I
miss you take care yourself man I don't
want to hear about something happening
to you while you're in the military but
I appreciate it like I definitely
appreciate you watching my content um
hopefully it'll be here when you get
back hopefully my channel will be here
when you when you when you come back
will you do black Batman Black Mirror
eventually please I know others have
done it but not as detailed with your
amazing with the amazing ones you have
family Erick Hernandez Oh Erick
Hernandez
yes I will do black mirror at some point
alone once again Vinny and I try to give
ourselves some breathing room between
the time that we publish on essential
stories that is to say stories that like
are not huge in 10 poll we try to get
myself some breathing room usually a few
weeks sometimes even close to a month or
a little bit longer and I know he just
did a black mirror not too long ago so
I'm gonna hold off on that until here
until we give ourselves a little bit of
room but I would love to hear a bit a
bit more about Mephisto doesn't seem to
be much of on him out there there really
isn't there really isn't a whole lot on
him out there he just kind of shops that
shows up as a plot device and and that's
you know that's kind of it Howard the
Duck episode already did a video on
Howard the Duck I thought I did hey Rob
are you going to finish visions family
uh yeah me at some point probably when
we get closer to like infinity war
someone those lines are you know when he
appears again um I mean it's kind of a
cool story but in all honesty it was
also kind of hitting this I mean Tim kar
Tom
Tom King Tim King did a really good job
with vision but I think that I might
kind of hold off into the next one or
until sometime soon before I do that the
second part are you hyped about season 3
of Young Justice also please explain
superboy-prime I've done a video a
supercrime I do have a superboy-prime
explained and I've okay confession
confession time guys please don't yell
at me confession time I've never watched
Young Justice Young Justice I've never
watched what is your opinion on the new
52 features in didn't like it sexy core
Hawks what kind of a name is that I did
not like it I did not like new 52
futures and it just felt unnecessary it
felt like I didn't go towards anything
yeah I didn't care for it at all uh Jose
Otero thank you for the content
seriously thank you I appreciate that
hey Rob can you tell me happy birthday
my name is Greg that comes from zine Z
night I guess it is Z night happy
birthday Greg happy birthday to you um
best mean whatever is the best thing
come out of DC rebirthing fell on the
blank here is the best thing coming out
of DC rebirth one day I will collage
with you I promise from reject and
gamers who do you think picked up the
hammer of ultimate Thor I have no idea
and I've inspected let me tell you
something I'm in speculating on that
fanboy I've been speculating on that so
bad I really want to know I really want
to know who was it pick up the hammer of
Thor like I really want to know who
picked up Ultima Thor's hammer um I have
no idea
maybe it's Loki maybe maybe it's
actually ultimate for you know maybe
that's really just you know who it is I
haven't I have no earthly clue who that
could possibly be will be ty the poor
soul who doesn't finish a Quinn's run
and as a secret warriors explain
seriously Rob secret warriors are so
underrated what are you going to do it
never really thought about doing secret
warriors I guess I could but I never
really gave it a whole lot of thought no
no maybe I will at some point I mean
it's cool I mean it's super cool like
you know Daisy Johnson everything was
pretty solid that's part of that for
those of you guys who don't know that's
part of Hickman's whole like
self-contained line of stories fantastic
for shield secret warriors Avengers no
Avengers are you am I ever going to
write a comic of your own oh god okay so
imagine this so imagine this alright
give me a second on this guy's like like
I want you guys to imagine this this
phenomena this to me would be an awesome
Batman comic alright imagine that like
Bruce Wayne is like an older guy right
like he's in his home he's an older guy
his worlds just kind of gone to pot and
that's really about it and you know all
the superheroes are gone you know let's
say that that Superman was killed or
something like that by Lex Luthor and
those lines and like the flash is left
you know for whatever reason Wonder
Woman returned at the mascara Green
Lantern Hal Jordan and Guy Gardner and
Jon Stewart were recalled back to the
center of the universe I don't know what
inner whatever reason you want but
anyway crime is basically just kind of
run amok and Batman is doing all he can
to keep Gotham City together it's like
Hammonds cyborg and the Justice League
Watchtower like these only two keeping
it together he's at his wits end he's on
the verge of giving up alright and then
the window smashes and in through the
window comes a Blue Lantern ring and it
just says Bruce Wayne you have the power
to instill great hope and then just like
jump back to the beginning of the story
how it all started like to me that would
be so so badass longtime fan thanks for
doing injustice would you I would like
would like to see dammit all these oh
dammit that questions go on no no I lost
that question no I waited too long
captain caret already came out that
sucks
I'm sorry gotta get to finish your
question um I love how much you love
comics it's so easy to be negative about
mainstream superhero books you've missed
marvelous shots on Tom I need to I
really needed like to do a video on her
like I really needed to do that at some
point um but thank you for for digging
my content I'm so thankful to you for
a continent who inspired me to read my
my old comics to my seven-year-old and
started getting him very interested he
now has a subscription for Aquaman M
Aquaman M sub G oh okay for Aquaman
Green Lantern and flash Oh Aquaman
Superman Green Lantern Oh flash that's
awesome like I'm glad I was able to kind
of help you bond you know and and and
pull that off I really I really
appreciate that message comes from
Plinko four six eight three five Thank
You Plinko I feel weird call him deep
link oh by the way that's an amazing
game on The Price is Right those you
guys don't know your content is amazing
and it's taken me from damn it and has
taken me from please tell me we didn't
lose that that comment oh god you two
need to do something about how long
these comments last for no I missed that
I'm sorry I missed that
Brian Martin died mister didn't get a
chance to read your comment damn it I
guess you have to be fast it's not fair
it's not fair to the people who comment
like that YouTube heaven YouTube you're
killing me okay guys a few more
questions than I got a I got a bounce
off here like it's it's almost it's like
almost 11:30 almost 12 o'clock here and
I got to be up to catch my flight back
home but but yeah I I do want to
collaborate with you guys okay um so
some more some more non donation
questions Rob please cover black
lightning please never thought about how
many black lightning I don't really even
know anything about black yeah I guess I
need to do some reading up town I do
like a black lightning explained um
do you would you ever do an episode on
warlock I have but I need to remaster it
I have that's one of the things I intend
to do with guardians of the galaxy's
release actually is remaster because I
want to get back into character
discussions having more free-flowing
discussions and I need to remaster
the Adam warlock video so I think
they'll be kind of a good place to start
to sort of regain my bearings
Vernon Singh Wow thank you um no idea
what currency that is but I appreciate
it um let's see all right will you cover
secret Empire and all of Hydra cap oh
yeah it's one of the best stories out
there right now it's hands down some of
the absolute best how would you feel
about the Titans or Jonathan Kent Damian
Wayne Wally West etcetera taking the
mantle of the Justice League as they
retire I mean now with that does have me
the team having like the Titans become
the Justice League members like the the
Teen Titans and the Titans become
members of the Justice League
you know once the the other members
leave yeah oh yeah I'll be down with
that I think we're pretty solid um let's
see what's your opinion on infamous Iron
Man I love it oh my god I love infamous
Iron Man like it's it's some that is an
example of a story where Jonathan
Hickman actually gives a damn that's
what that is there's a story where
Hitler were not Eggman Brian Michael
Bendis actually cares it's definitely a
story where Bendis really cares about
what he's running anyway guys we gotta
wrap this episode up I know there's a
few questions that went unanswered I'm
sorry I got a rather somebody to get
some sleep and I'm exhausted
and yeah so what about 33 minutes I
think I might do this more often
especially cuz I don't have to set up
the whole livestream thing for comics
and coffee I think I might I think I
might do this you know kind of keep this
going every weekend or something like
that like every Sunday or something
along those lines dude you're awesome
keep it up you guys are awesome I
appreciate it without you guys my
channel would not be where it's at so so
yes we're gonna cover Sinestro Corps war
definitely but anyway guys I'm gonna
bounce off here
I know catch you all later please